l'image la plus choquante qui a le plus
fait parler forcément le plus fait le
tour et qui a fait vraiment le plus
réagir parce que ça on a eu on a eu très
peur d'ailleurs pour pour ce policier
c'est ce j'ai de cocktail Molotov par
des manifestants qui atteint un groupe
de force de l'ordre et l'un d'eux a pris
feu regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dites quoi les images sont
extrêmement choquantes mais la réalité
elle est encore plus choquante quand on
est sur le terrain et ma première
réaction ça a été de me dire merci merci
aux collègues policiers qui sont
intervenus très vite pour faire cesser
ça mais quand ce policier là il se passe
ça moi je me suis pensé à lui moyen je
me suis dit derrière sa famille c'est
s'il a des enfants sa famille lui dit
stop on arrête il va plus ça y est c'est
un avertissement c'est terminé alors il
y a les blessures physiques il y a les
blessures psychologiques les blessures
physiques une pensée pour lui il est
vraiment blessé avec des brûlures au
premier degré au deuxième degré sur le
visage sur les membres
il va il est arrêté de nombreuses
semaines il va avoir des interventions
chirurgicales on sait à quel point elles
sont douloureuses et il y a le choc
psychologique
[Musique]
vraiment j'espère qu'il est qu'il est
très entouré par les policiers de la 12e
compagnie d'Internet à lui ce soir
le collectif peut beaucoup aider aussi
les policiers qui sont voilà sont son
entourage proche il va partager beaucoup
avec eux ils vont l'aider qui fait ça
qui fait ça c'est pas les manifestants
on les voit ici viennent ils veulent
manifester ils veulent voilà le
président est encore dit on a tous le
droit de manifester et ne pas être
d'accord avec avec une loi etc et c'est
le droit de manifester là hier
vous avez dit il y a plus la plupart des
manifestations qui sont bien passées et
puis il y avait des débordements qui ont
été plus graves on a l'impression à nous
de l'extérieur plus grave que que ce
qu'il y avait eu avant
ce qui fait ça c'est Black Bloc alors
qui fait ça c'est des Black Blocs c'est
des individus radicaux
qui sont qui veulent en découdre
clairement ils sont suivis par les
services du renseignement on savait on
l'avait prévu 1500 à 2000 élément
radicaux sur la manifestation
certains sont fichiers pas tous certains
viennent de l'étranger mais ça français
avec une mouvance d'ultra-goche mais il
y a aussi plein de Black Blocs qui ne
croient rien ils veulent juste se casser
casser du flic ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux c'est cassé des devantures
créer de la violence créer
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux quoi
ils sont nombreux on les suit là ce qui
s'est passé c'est que certains éléments
sont venus de l'étranger aussi donc ça
ça a ramené un nombre supérieur par
rapport à d'habitude un peu comme sur
les la manifestation à sainte-souligne
il y a quelques semaines il y avait
aussi des éléments venus de l'étranger
on s'attendait à ça après quand on le
vit quand on le vit sur le terrain comme
les gendarmes les policiers les préfets
qui étaient aussi présents le préfet de
police et les préfets dans les autres
départements c'est rude une pensée aussi
à tous les policiers légendaires qui ont
eux aussi été blessés ils sont plusieurs
centaines la CRS 15 un policier
blessé des gendarmes aussi gendarmes à
Clermont-Ferrand notamment donc tous les
blessés sur d'autres images c'est pas la
seule image de violence hier qu'on a vu
gâcher des jets de projectiles charges
des policiers ont été pris aussi pour
cible dans la manifestation regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si vous voyez les
projectiles en fait on voit des pierres
il y a des bouteilles en verre il y a
des marteaux on a on a ces idées
couteaux des armes blanches sur les
individus interpellés ils ont été très
nombreux d'ailleurs faut bien voir que
tout ça c'est fait pour tuer c'est pas
juste fait pour pour blesser c'est fait
pour tuer et c'était l'état d'esprit de
ces Black Blocs et c'est contre ça qu'on
lutte sur ce type de manifestation
heureusement une fois de plus beaucoup
beaucoup se passe bien
mais quand il y a des facteurs de risque
comme c'était le cas hier on sait que
c'est ça qui attend les policiers
légendes là l'enquête est ouverte pour
tentative d'homicide donc clairement
c'est une volonté de tuer le policier
moi ma question sur les Black Blocs je
sais que c'est compliqué parce que comme
ils sont pas en association vous ne
pouvez pas les dissoudre mais néanmoins
vous le disiez on les connaît ils sont
suivis pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne les
empêche pas d'aller dans le pré-corpège
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas à titre
préventif une interdiction faite à ces
gens-là de venir alors il y a une partie
qu'on empêche c'est des choses qui
peuvent qui peuvent arriver en termes
administratif il y a des mesures de
police administratives qui peuvent être
appliquées parfois après c'était du
temps du ministre d'intérieur Christophe
Castaner il y avait une loi
anti-casseurs qui que le ministre
voulait faire passer elle avait été
invalidée partiellement par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc certains lois
certaines réflexions se valider par le
Conseil constitutionnel pas la loi pas
la loi pas la réforme
à trouver et je crois que le ministère
de l'Intérieur veut remettre ça sur sur
le sur le sur le métier pour
retravailler des dispositions qui
pourraient cette fois-ci être valides
aussi du travail à faire et je le disais
avec nos partenaires étrangers parce que
l'Allemagne l'Italie ils ont à peu près
les mêmes problèmes sur certaines
manifestations et donc déjà éviter cette
arrivée de personnes étrangères qui
viennent en renfort de ces de ces ultras
on va les appeler comme ça ça aiderait
il y a eu il y a eu combien
d'arrestations alors plus de 500 c'est
quand même énorme les fois on attend un
peu ça devient quoi après mais le
problème
parce que parmi ces 500 personnes il y a
eu des Black Blocs qui ont été
appréhendés à mon avis ils viennent quoi
parce que on le dit là j'ai vu encore un
rapport qui disait que les prisons n'ont
jamais été aussi pleines comment vous
faites derrière alors il y a de la
prison mais ça peut être d'autres types
de mesure notamment financières on dit
souvent touché au portefeuille ça marche
et puis des mesures d'interdiction par
exemple de paraître à Paris comme ça la
prochaine manifestation elle ne
viendront pas ça dépend en fait de ce
que va décider le juge nous au service
de police et du gendarmerie on doit
rassembler des preuves et des preuves on
en a on a des images on a des
interpellations on rassemble tout ça et
puis après c'est la justice qui tranche
c'est ça l'État de droit mais oui vous
pensez voilà donc là donc oui les
sanctions pénales sont pas assez sévères
tout le monde le dit non non pas du tout
mais c'est pas du tout une accusation
mais c'est vrai il y a un vrai problème
parce que effectivement on peut les
empêcher pendant une période de venir
aux manifestations mais après ils
peuvent revenir et puis c'est difficile
de les identifier donc aujourd'hui on a
presque l'impression qu'il y a une sorte
d'impunité des Black Blocs alors c'est
pas une affinité on marche vraiment sur
sur deux jambes le volet administratif
préventif et là il y a plein de choses
nouvelles qui se passent par exemple
utilisation des drones c'est la première
semaine où on peut commencer à les
utiliser et on a vu ça marche à Lyon on
a interpellé plus de 30 personnes qui
saccagaient une enseigne Monoprix pour
pour voilà pour créer de la violence on
a pu les interpeller grâce aux droits
donc tout ça c'est préventif et puis
après il y a le judiciaire et nous notre
travail les forces de l'ordre c'est de
rassembler les preuves et après c'est
l'équilibre des pouvoirs c'est pas nous
qui décidons des suites mais c'est vrai
quand on a beaucoup investi de temps de
travail pour interpeller rassembler des
preuves on aimerait que les sanctions
judiciaires sont importantes sur la base
des personnes qui ont été interpellées
est-ce qu'on sait qui sont les Black
Blocs parce qu'il paraît qu'il y a des
gens en fait de plein de milieux sociaux
différents que c'est pas forcément des
marginaux et que ça peut être des gens
parfois de milieux aisés aussi alors
c'est vrai par contre il y a une
caractéristique qui qui est vrai c'est
que c'est beaucoup beaucoup des hommes
donc voilà il y a pas une parité dans
tous ou dans tout cela mais vous avez
raison c'est différent milieu et c'est
des méthodes des fois assez archaïques
finalement pour se rassembler pour se
regrouper c'est pas forcément des gens
extrêmement modernes donc tout ça on
apprend aussi à les connaître pour mieux
les entraver et ça c'est le travail
notamment des renseignements et du
renseignement territorial
particulièrement